given your background given the work
that you've done how would you describe
the current status of Consciousness
research and the theories around it
well we're at a very interesting time
um I believe it was just widely reported
that you know a long-standing bet over
whether or not Consciousness would be
resolved was notoriously not resolved um
who made the bet I believe it was
Chalmers and Christoph if I'm not
mistaken
who's talking about being a a very
famous neuroscientist in the field and
David Chalmers being a very famous
philosopher who was who was for which oh
uh Chalmers was of course was the
philosopher was against it and the
scientist was for it
um and
and if you if if you think about sort of
where we are
um
in the search for a scientific theory of
consciousness
you know it wasn't even on the table
that you could do something like that
that you could look for a scientific
theory of Consciousness you know as as I
talk about in the book consciousness was
very explicitly split off from science
early on in the beginning I mean
particularly by Galileo who who
basically said you know let's not worry
about
qualitative aspects of the world let's
not worry about the redness of red or or
how a peach tastes you know or the sound
of a trombone let's just focus on the
quantitative aspects of the world which
we can describe mathematically
and and and let's just bracket this
problem aside and and to him right he
you know he was a religious man right he
would have said it as you know it's just
it's just not science's business to go
poking around in the soul just put it
aside and lets you focus on this this
universe that God is created for us and
that that strategy has actually been the
fundamental strategy of Science and is
one of the things that has made it so
successful and so able to sort of
proceed without people
um without essentially annoying
philosophers coming in and saying well
you're not really explaining this right
but of course there is a science where
you do need to explain uh qualitative
properties and that's Neuroscience uh to
figure out how the brain works you need
to understand how Consciousness Works
um and and we simply don't and for a
long time Neuroscience has been hobbled
by the fact that it has been
fundamentally behaviorist and people
have been incredibly scared to talk
about or mention consciousness
and it really took two different men
winning two different Nobel prizes
Francis Crick who co-discovered DNA and
uh Gerald Edelman
um who who was one of the people who
really figured out how the immune system
functions and they both got their Nobel
prizes in a different field and they
looked at neuroscience and said there is
a big unanswered scientific question
here which is how does the brain create
Consciousness and they both sort of
started up their own institutes and
their own
um sort of ways to approach this problem
but you know had had it not had the
weight of two Nobel prizes behind it
um I don't I I think that there still
wouldn't even be any serious uh
scientific attempt to understand
consciousness
and Neuroscience
um and and and I think without that
Neuroscience struggles a great deal I
mean that's that's another thing that's
that a a chunk of the book is about is
just about the essentially the Scandal
that is modern Neuroscience given that
the stream of Consciousness is what your
brain
um you know that's the main function of
the brain is generating your stream of
Consciousness so imagine you're trying
to figure out an organ and you're not
allowed to talk about its main function
yeah you're sort of forced to talk
around it yeah it would be like being a
Formula One racing reporter but all of
your discussions being about the grass
on the side of the track and yeah the
the temperature of the air and the flags
waving in the Wind
exactly and so people tried to sort of
skirt around it by taking aspects of how
Consciousness works like attention and
saying okay well we we're allowed to
talk about attention we can focus on
attention you know and and uh and we can
focus on memory right like we we can do
things sort of without reference to the
stream of Consciousness but of course
you know when you remember something
you're you're conscious of it and when
you attend to something you're conscious
of it these are all things it's just
something that happened there's a
phenomenological experience which is
associated with it
exactly and so people tried to sort of
preserve the um non-subjectivity of
Science and not not let subjectivity in
by by sequestering away a lot of these
mental properties and sort of them
pretending that that Consciousness uh
doesn't exist but it it has not I'll
just be very honest I have a PhD in
Neuroscience
um it has not been very successful I
mean I I don't think Neuroscience has
has made really I'll say it any
significant um advancement since I
really entered the field in terms of not
not in terms of everything but in terms
of understanding most of the major
questions that people want to know about
how the brain operates so stuff at a
very high cognitive level how does the
brain operate Neuroscience has not made
a significant progress and it's probably
because you're not really even allowed
in most areas Neuroscience to talk about
the main function what do you mean when
you say not allowed is there there's
some policeman that comes and slaps you
on the back of the wrist as soon as you
start typing about it like what you're
on about
well within science there there are all
sorts of you know structures that that
um you know prevent somebody from from
getting crazy I mean I I think more
fundamentally it's just been that uh you
know due to legacies of things like
behaviorism uh talking about
Consciousness has been considered sort
of too dangerous and it's been actively
discouraged and you'll you can still go
and find a neuroscientist and you'll
you'll ask them you know what are your
thoughts on Consciousness and they'll
either say you know I don't have any or
they'll say that's it's sort of woo you
know and and then you know the
conversation gets very strange very
quickly because you say well what do you
mean by that you're saying that we don't
we're not conscious or or what are you
saying and then they have to have some
sort of convoluted definition where you
get to keep attention in memory and all
these other things but you're not
allowed to talk about consciousness
but there are it's not it's not a
conspiracy to keep Consciousness
um out of the field it's just how the
intellectual lineage of the field
developed is that any real discussion of
Consciousness which should be the major
part of Neuroscience is kept as this
very sort of minor set of now thanks to
the big names of the field not everyone
in it is considered a very strange
weirdo but in 1985 right like like 1985
you could not just go and get a PhD like
I did studying the Neuroscience of
Consciousness that that was not a thing
that could happen in fact my generation
is the first generation to really be
able to actively get into the field in
order to study Consciousness and then
actively work on that throughout our
careers rather than essentially having
to become neurofamous you know for some
other thing and then sort of transition
once no one can criticize you and
science is very conservative like I
don't think people should be surprised
again it's not conspiratorial uh you
know the same sort of stuff happens in
theoretical physics where maybe there
are some promising approaches and
they're just like not favored by the
field or sort of viewed as as as as
crazy and so on and um and and so it's
very difficult to to do work in it but I
think if you look at Neuroscience as a
whole and where it is
um you know it has sort of all sorts of
all sorts of problems that that crop up
almost endlessly within it and you have
these repeating narratives and these
sort of neural myths that don't die and
so on and I think a lot of it is just
that there's no big Target of
Neuroscience there's no big Target of
what to figure out because what to
figure out is how the brain generate
Consciousness and only a small subfield
of Neuroscience even looks at that now
feeling the Aftershock of Galileo still
all of these Millennia later yes
absolutely absolutely
um but he would of course been um you
know I I think it's more likely that it
had you I I've been a philosopher named
Philip Goff makes this point uh makes
this thought experiment of like if you
brought Galileo out to the Modern Age
and you said okay we're trying to do
this Neuroscience of Consciousness he
would probably say well no stop you know
you're not supposed to do that that's
this weird perversion of science right
like you this that's the domain of the
soul of course you're not finding any
satisfactory answers it feels like do
you know what it feels like to me as
you're talking about it obviously all of
the problems of Consciousness are Myriad
and very difficult to try and come up
with and as you've said yourself your
entire field that you have a PhD and
then have worked in for almost all your
life until you just left has made
basically very little progress with it
it feels a little bit like you know when
you hear about in UFC or in boxing
there's this one fighter that no one
wants to call out and all of the
fighters are calling out the other ones
that they know are kind of a bit
than this one but there's this one guy
and he's just a nightmare he's a Phenom
and no one can handle him it feels a
little bit like Consciousness is the
difficult fighter that no one wants to
call out
yeah absolutely and it's one reason why
I don't always encourage younger people
to go into the field despite the fact
that it's one of the biggest open
questions in science which is that it's
also probably if not the most difficult
question in science it's one of the most
difficult questions in science
um
and we're still waiting on our Einstein
we're waiting on our Darwin
um and and it's sort of sad because
Neuroscience is entering this period
particularly with AI where you know
people are are able to predict various
things off of brain States right like
you might think well you know how come
Eric is saying that uh you know
Neuroscience hasn't been any progress
didn't I just see some something about
how AIS can now read your mind off of
neuroimaging or something like that
right and the answer is is that all that
stuff is statistical so it's it's sort
of like like first it's it's the the AIS
are you know very very good at
extrapolating from minimal data so if
you actually look at what it's
predicting it's it's actually not the
same at all and it's sort of like uh you
know how it's able to auto complete the
next paragraph of of text right
but
um
you know the thing is is that there is
some law there is some law of nature
wherein the neural activity that your
brain is undergoing now is associated
with generates you can sort of come up
with with various relational terms here
but is related to your conscious the
conscious things that you are
experiencing right so you know if you're
if you're listening to this podcast
you're the the the the auditory cortex
is is going through you know various
sort of stages of processing there is
some there is somewhere there uh law of
nature that tells us okay what sounds
are now being experienced right like
that that is a question
um it's not just you know can I throw
machine learning at it and sort of like
Get The Sounds back or tell that someone
is is experiencing something it's very
similar to to the laws of physics right
despite all the complexity that you of
of you know leaves falling from trees
there are natural laws behind those and
science knows most of those natural laws
particularly at the skills that are
relevant
within the brain we don't have anything
like that
um and and you can one way to tell this
is that you ask Neuroscience
neuroscientists to explain things and I
used to do this all I was a menace in
graduate school because I do this all
the time uh where I would ask you know
some prominent neuroscientists you know
who had who's an expert at some you know
highly particular field to to explain
that phenomenon right like auditory
processing or something and then they
would give their explanation and then I
would ask them to please explain it
again but don't refer to location
right don't don't just tell me where in
the brain this is happening tell me how
it's happening right like like
because what is the spatial information
tell us that it's over there or over
there this this isn't that's not real
scientific understanding that's sort of
like well if I damage that part of the
brain this no longer works right and if
you remove localization
what you'll find is that the the outside
of some very early sensory processing
that we know we we know how it works
things like Edge detection uh Envision
so like but that's very you know primary
sensory courtesy uh sort of stuff right
this is the shallows of the brain once
you start moving beyond the shelves of
the brain and you talk about the Deep
areas of the brain and you get people
talking about them you'll notice and you
remove something like localization you
notice there's almost nothing to say
yeah I'm thinking about I'm thinking
about back to a lot of the conversations
that I've had on Neuroscience with
neuroscientists the stuff that I've
listened to or read
and an awful lot of it does sort of come
in with a slam dunk in a way which is a
particular thing happens and here is the
area of the brain which is activated or
you take a particular substance and this
is the pattern of behavior within the
brain which is turned down and this is
the pattern which is turned up and these
it's it's
almost like cranial geography more than
it is like an explanation of the
phenomenological experience of being a
human
right and you could you know imagine
that you you sort of swapped around all
those locational tags well what would
that change right you would say oh well
you know the you know auditory
processing occurs in the front right and
then in another stuff occurs you know
far in the back right like you could
swap around all that stuff and and you
wouldn't feel any different about about
the system and that's a good um that's a
good indication that your your
explanations are not very meaningful
um and you know the the fundamental
truth is that we don't even know that
there is no good way to even understand
how artificial neural networks function
once they get past a certain size they
become mathematical black boxes and this
is a really big problem it's a big
problem for AI safety I know you've had
on guests who've talked about AI safety
that's a cause area I care uh quite
about but quite a bit about but
um you know one thing that makes that so
difficult is that it's almost impossible
to figure out what a feed forward AI
which is made of structured sets of of
effectively neural neurons mathematical
representations of neurons
where we can know all the connections
and we know exactly what neurons are
firing and so on we have perfect
information and we're still stumped in
uh in a significant number of cases
Neuroscience is is is a thousand times
harder than figuring out how some feed
forward neural network uh uh is not only
is the brain much larger in terms of the
parameter size you know we probably have
something like 100 trillion synapses
um we're also you know it's also
occluded behind an opaque wall of bone
um and it's incredibly delicate and it's
all folded up
um and and then and and so you know
another question that I like to ask
neuroscientists is okay so why should we
feel that the brain will be so much more
easier to to figure out than like a
relatively much smaller artificial
neural network that we have perfect
information in our access to and we
still can't figure out that so why why
would you not expect that black box
aspect to to exist in the brain
I've never gotten like a like a good
answer uh to some Eric I I I can't
imagine why you are now out of Academia
given that you've made every academic
that you've worked with for the last
decade life a nightmare no no no no no
no no no no I just got a lovely email
from a graduate student
um from a former graduate student
um that was just um that was an absolute
tree to read about how great working
with me was so I'm sure I'm sure no no I
I I I think I think you're you're you're
right in the sense of um
in in the sense of you know you one has
to distinguish between being a gadfly
and actually offering something positive
so the thing is is that it's very easy
to sit on your high horse and critique
critique a field like Neuroscience which
is trying to understand the most complex
system they don't know this and they
don't know this and this is useless and
blah blah blah right and and so what I
you know also focused on what point in
my career was was that well one one way
to understand the complexities of the
brain is that probably that that
Consciousness has something to do with
it so pursuing a scientific theory of
consciousness
should help you uh you know answer these
questions because in theory there is
some sort of natural law that relates
you know experiences and much of the
much of the the fluff of Neuroscience is
just that the field is
um in
in um philosophy of science terms it's
just pre-paradigmatic so because it's
prepared thematic it has all these
problems but that doesn't mean you
should stop stop working on the field
what it means is that you should work
very hard to try to develop a a new
paradigm uh what's just for the people
that don't know what's pre-paragdigmatic
that would be that there's no
overarching Paradigm to explain uh
there's no sort of like big theory that
everyone can key off of and understand
so a great example of this would be
biology before Darwin so until you have
the theory of natural selection you do
have biology right people are out there
collecting taximonies and making
scientific observations and you know
relating the lineages of species and so
on but once you get the theory of
evolution by natural selection the whole
thing clicks into place and you're sort
of able to fit everything within this um
you know this this overarching structure
which I suppose also includes criticism
them
yes yes certainly but and and just
because you Advanced to one Paradigm
does not mean that the science is now
over in fact what usually happens is
that science advances to a paradigm and
then all sorts of Errors begin to crop
up in various places
um and and um Thomas Cooper was one
of the people who really wrote a lot
about this uh these errors crop up and
once the errors reach a certain point
we're like no one can really deny them
anymore
uh finally people are sort of forced to
search for some new paradigm and uh and
and they get some sort of replacement
and you've seen this happen in physics
right where it's like you know the the
the early almost
um solar system-esque models of atoms
right that you might have seen in
textbooks of course that's not really
what atoms look like that's sort of an
earlier more you know easily to
understand paradigm of what atoms look
like and we went through you know
successive uh paradigms but I think
within Neuroscience it's still very much
waiting on its big Theory it's still
very much waiting on a theory of
Consciousness and that would be the
thing that catapults it to being uh post
paramedic and so that's where you know I
hope that like the the criticisms I'm
offering forth including some in this
book do have a do have a Positive
Purpose right which is to sort of
reorientate people towards
um you know where can we actually move
in order to solve some of these uh these
sort of problems instead of just
continuing down doing exactly what we're
doing okay so explain to me the
intrinsic and the extrinsic perspective
and how those tie in and how they're
related sure so I if if we if we go back
to Galileo the intrinsic is is what he
removed right is what he cut out
um and the extrinsic is in a way were
sort of more well-versed in or were more
familiar with so an engineering diagram
would be extrinsic
um the the the mathematics
um you know a physical description of
some complex natural phenomena and that
would be an extrinsic description uh the
the circuitry of your laptop that would
be an extrinsic description a causal
model is extrinsic intrinsic
are the subjective qualities that
accompany your or you know are basically
are your conscious experience and your
stream of Consciousness and Neuroscience
fits in this very strange uh position
where it's trying to reconcile the the
intrinsic and the extrinsic
um something that is very interesting to
me and and um you know I devoted again
some of the book some of the books about
this
is that if you look at the development
of our civilization you can as in
humanity as a whole you can view
uh you could view it as the development
of these two different perspectives on
the world
and and they don't they don't really go
together right
um one is is our development of the
extrinsic right so and the separation of
the two so if you look early on of
course people are explaining things with
Gods
um you know or magic or these other sort
of much more like Supernatural
phenomenon and suddenly we get honed
down to only really wanting to give very
clear extrinsic explanations of
phenomena and the the best example of
that is in science
but Meanwhile we're also beginning to
understand that we also you know over
time over the Millennia we get much
better at describing not just the
extrinsic world like via science is on
we also get better at describing the
intrinsic world
so we get better at describing ourselves
and our own emotions and our own
thoughts and we have better theory of
mind we have better
um ability to express our own minds and
sort of the the the various details and
and and and all sort of the the
the the the
micro quanta of your own conscious
experience
um we get much much better at that you
know if you go back and you read
um you know ancient Egyptian poetry or
ancient Egyptian texts what you'll find
is that descriptions of Mind are
incredibly sparse uh they you really
don't get very many descriptions of
emotions and the descriptions of
emotions that you do get are extremely
wooden
um it's almost as if you know you have
literature but then you sort of don't
even know how to really talk about other
Minds and it's just like with science
the ability to describe mine sort of
rockets forward during the um they're an
era of ancient Greece and post the
homeric era and you see europides and
all these playwrights become you know
extremely
um
extremely good at describing Minds uh in
ways that we would recognize now
um and then funnily enough I mean after
the the fall of the Roman Empire
um you know during research for this
book I was sort of going through
going through history and trying to find
uh you know text through which you would
uh would be good examples of how people
talk about minds in different eras right
and uh it was it's actually very hard to
find any text at all uh that talks about
minds post follow the Roman Empire like
when you're in the Dark Ages
um and so you really sort of you really
sort of lose this ability almost outside
of some
you know uh religious text you really
lose this ability to really talk
seriously about minds
um I almost almost as if we like
reverted back to ancient Egypt and then
we you know develop it again just like
with science
um you know um during the Enlightenment
and so on and and that was a really sort
of fascinating story that I didn't sort
of expect uh expect Opera
um it really kind of fell out of out of
my research and looking at these these
twin threads and you know the intrinsic
perspective just like
just like we we
took the extrinsic perspective on the
world and we boiled it away to its
clearest form and that's science we took
the intrinsic perspective of the world
and we boiled it away to the clearest
expression of it and that's literature
um and and that's the if you go back and
you read
um you know
um you know 18th century novelists right
they they have such facility with
describing internal States
um and that would have been completely
foreign to people 2000 years ago
um and it's as if they sort of developed
um you know of a Viewpoint
um just in the same way that science was
developed except that Viewpoint is
pointed towards Consciousness it's
pointed towards
um accessing and describing our our
qualitative experiences yeah that's very
interesting that you could almost look
at
novels and the literature as
probably more well it almost certainly
is more of a direct window into the Mind
than the science of the brain and the
signs of Consciousness you learn an
awful lot more functionally
experientially about what it's like to
be a human by reading
Wuthering Heights or something
then you do
by looking at Neuroscience journals yeah
absolutely I mean you know there's just
no doubt that Tolstoy knew more about
human nature than some contemporary
psychologist even like an evolutionary
psychologist right like you can take you
know some sort of evolutionary
psychologist say you know explain human
nature and then Tolstoy comes in with
you know very sort of what we would
consider perhaps very strange archaic
you know Notions of you know true
Christianity and and how human beings
work and then he somehow you know is
able to sort of explain explain people
just so incredibly well and has such an
eye for how humans actually function
um and and can write across all sorts of
different you know divides
um
and and I do think that that's
what what's really interesting there is
that where that failure is is in the
missing sort of Neuroscience of
Consciousness right if one reason for
that one reason that feels like such an
obvious Gap
is because Neuroscience is sort of
continuously stuck trying to explain the
everything via the extrinsic perspective
um and we never quite get what we want
from the brain out of such explanations
we always feel that there's something
fundamentally missing we always feel
that there's some ghost that's been left
out of the machine
um whenever we sort of try to give an ex
perfectly extrinsic explanation of the
brain how is Descartes involved or
important in this story
well I think I think Descartes is you
know deeply important whenever you talk
about
um whenever you talk about Consciousness
but but specifically for this
um you know he actually has this really
interesting interaction where this
problem of how does how does the
intrinsic relate to the extrinsic I mean
perhaps it's most its first historical
formal discussion occurs in some letters
that Descartes sends uh with Princess
Elizabeth of bohemia
um who was
um a really really interesting woman
um she was a mathematician she was a
philosopher she eventually uh became an
abbess of a of of a
um I think I forget exactly in which
country she was an abyss but but she she
lived this life that was filled with
sort of political Intrigue she was a
royal and she met Descartes and their
letters are fascinating historical
reading I mean one because there's
almost like this extremely romantic
aspect of it and of course you know that
that age was very different and how
people spoke to one another was very
different but you sort of you sort of
get the sense that these are like two
nerds you know communicating over emails
um you know but but they're like stuck
you know in the Renaissance
um and and and uh and after Descartes
died uh princess Elizabeth never married
um and and and and and died Widow and um
to turn down an offer of marriage I was
given to her um
and and and she was reportedly just
utterly heartbroken but the point is
that in these letters princess Elizabeth
um who was a very good philosopher in
her own right makes a point to Descartes
about his metaphysics and he is one of
the people who really initially pushed
this ideal idea of dualism
um it's almost a caricature at this
point where you know he's like the soul
interacts with the body through the
pineal gland his opinions were a bit
more complicated than that but you know
that's effectively how it's how it's
portrayed and
um you know princess Elizabeth has this
point where she says well consider that
you know sort of physics in the world is
extrinsic and the soul is intrinsic how
can one impact the other if they're if
they really are if you really are a
dualist and you really think they're two
different types of substances how can
one sort of causally control the other
that seems that seems nonsensical
that's the Pillow Talk That I Want by
the way that foreplay for me I just
dismantle my life's work and and use the
word ridiculous yeah
um and and and you do sort of get the
get the sense of that where she's she's
both complimenting him but also you know
clearly clearly sort of like a bulldog
has has got a hold of this point and and
won't won't let go until Descartes you
know really gives her uh the answer
she's she's looking for and he he really
doesn't do a good job of it right he he
first he sort of says well maybe this is
like gravity where it's a force right
and she immediately comes back with well
if it's a force like gravity then the
mind would just be material right
because it would just be some physical
Force so what again what do you mean by
saying it's two separate substances how
do they interact and uh they never
really resolve it Descartes sort of
ducks the question and they uh you know
their their correspondence continues on
on other matters
uh for a very long time uh until his
death uh but
that to me is so interesting
historically because it's a point where
where some of the paradoxes around
Consciousness come very clearly into
play
both of them have the very strong
intuition that you cannot reduce the
intrinsic to the extrinsic fully
and so they're saying you know there's
two separate substances and and
Elizabeth never you know questions that
she shares the same intuitions um and in
the modern day
you can go to philosophy of mine and you
can find all sorts of arguments
that argue exactly for that right so so
they argue exactly like example would be
like the zombie argument that uh again
the philosopher David Chalmers is very
famous for sort of articulating and
defending very well
um uh is an example something where it
primes your intuition to believe that
the interns in the extrins are really
fundamentally different
but Elizabeth also notes this
paradoxical aspect which is that well if
they are really different wait a minute
how could they even interact how could
our picture of the world even be
sensible right if there really are just
like two fundamentally incompatible
perspectives on the world and we don't
know how to reconcile that how does that
give us a cohesive ontology it doesn't
seem to do that and so that's really the
ultimate Paradox of
of Consciousness which is that both that
there are strong arguments and strong
intuitions for why
when you're talking about Consciousness
you're dealing with something that's
irreducible to the material but at the
same time it's totally unclear what the
ontology of the world would even look
like uh if it were true that
Consciousness was irreducible and the
Soul was you know moving around uh you
know the neurons in the pineal gland or
whatever right because presumably we
would just find the you know the force
coefficient or whatever of what the soul
is doing and give it some mathematical
description and then you know actually
wait it's just this force and we'd be
you know dismissive of it and find it
you know very boring and
non-supernatural and so on
um and so that to me they're sort of the
first like almost like Odd Couple who
who who fully recognize and their
correspondence this this paradoxical
aspect of Consciousness and one of the
things that makes it just so darn hard
yeah is this it
related in any way to the bicameral mind
and like that perspective that was
something that I first learned about
whilst watching Westworld
um which I guess might be the same for a
lot of people uh but I was fascinated by
that I was really really fascinated by
this idea of the bicameral mind and
again it seems like there's almost a
splitting up of what's going on there
too how does that kind of play into this
story yeah you know I think it was to to
paraphrase Umberto Echo you know a book
is made of other books
um Julian James wrote this this classic
um back in I mean 1976 called the the
origin of Consciousness and the
breakdown of the bicameral mind and one
of the things that's great about it is
that it's a beautifully written book
it's an example of a popular science
book that does not suck
um and it's it's really fascinating
because he proposes frankly a wild
hypothesis which is that
um you know the what we call Modern
Consciousness only came about during the
homeric ages and if you examine the
characters of The Iliad they don't
really talk about minds
um in the same way that we do they talk
about God's Commandments and so on and
so his speculation was that it's
essentially the the two hemispheres of
the brain we're still ultimately
disconnected during these times and that
they only sort of come together and
that's how you get modern Consciousness
and modern humans
now that that's a that's an incredibly
strong claim to make off of textual
evidence
right because that's really all uh
Julian James uh had and and because of
that Julian James is always considered
one of the first Consciousness
researchers because his ultimate
interest was in consciousness
uh but also he's he's always sort of
considered like it was a bit of a lark
right
um a a beautiful book A book that most
people who get into Consciousness
research have read and are interested in
uh but sort of a sort of a crazy one and
even very early on some initial reviews
of it you know philosophers who are now
uh you know still working and still very
well well renowned like Ned block wrote
some reviews of it that pointed out well
we don't have to have this complicated
hypothesis that Consciousness has
changed it's just that how people have
talked about Consciousness has changed
um and in a way a lot of a lot of my
book a lot of what the World Behind the
world is about
is is exploring this alternative View
and maybe a slightly more tame and
sensible one
um to the evidence that Julian James
brought forth about how in Italy and no
one was talking about minds and they
were talking about Gods instead and the
way that I frame it is is that you know
philosophers have these
these two different Notions of
Consciousness one is our phenomenal
Consciousness which is incredibly Rich
so phenomenal Consciousness includes
everything it's like to be you right now
all the little details of your
experience and the other is your access
Consciousness and that's all the stuff
about Consciousness that you can talk
about that you can express but we all
know that there's stuff within
Consciousness that you can't express
well right like you could talk about
your emotions but are you really fully
capturing your emotions when you talk
about them or are you sort of just it's
just tip of the iceberg stuff right and
so in the in sort of the narrative that
I that I paint is that um you know a lot
of the the stuff from Jillian James is
explained by thinking about it as uh the
story of our ability to talk about
consciousness
gets richer and richer and richer and
then finally it meets or begins to
approximate our actual Consciousness in
other words we start out historically
our Consciousness is very much like an
iceberg and we can only really talk
about you know very very uh you know top
of the line top of the line stuff for it
and
you know but once you once you move on
and once you keep going uh eventually
you uncover more and more of the iceberg
and you get better and better at talking
about your own Consciousness and in a
way that I think historically parallels
a lot of the developments of Science and
sort of reaches its apotheosis in
literature in the same way that the
extrinsic perspective reaches its
apotheosis in science do you think that
this is going to be a
a cause of sort of not necessarily
suffering but definitely discontent
among humans the fact that the richness
of our inner experience and the capacity
for us to explain and tell other people
about it at the moment are doomed to be
incredibly far apart
well I think we have it much better off
than we did historically right I mean I
think it's very hard to express what the
inner life of you know a Scandinavian
peasant you know in the 1100s was I
think that that's a very difficult
experience to to express and I don't
think that they had very many good
cognitive tools to express it I think
that we're we're sort of have been
gifted and people don't realize that
right it's one of the things that makes
modern humans seem so much more
intelligent
um than a lot of ancient texts if you go
back and you read historic literature
one of the things that you will think is
sort of like why are people so seemingly
dumb right like the average Twitter user
now seems far better to express their
own inner states you know than like the
very best Poets of Babylon right
um and and and is that we've inherited a
gift we've inherited all sorts of
cognitive tools and all sorts of of of
of of language in terms of words and
Concepts that allow us to talk talk
about our own
interstates and that's something that
was developed it was developed um a lot
by writers I think
um and that's an argument that I make
that you know if that that some of the
earliest that not just did writers get
better at expressing Consciousness but
they were inventing the very terminology
that you need in order to talk about
Consciousness and so you finally end up
with you know people like Virginia Woolf
or James Joyce who are able to you know
discuss the incredible minutia of
Consciousness and and transform it into
you know beautiful stream of
Consciousness stream of Consciousness
literature and that was one they they
that was their project right it wasn't
just
um something that they this is like
their style of writing that they you
know wanted to do they specifically were
like we're going to be the generation of
writers who gets the best at capturing
all the little details of Consciousness
and and so I think we owe a lot of our
our um language around Consciousness
um it and we have a debt uh to writers
and then also to you know psychologists
people like Freud although I think in
some ways the debt to him is negative
um that we have the set and we're able
to that therefore sort of express
ourselves
um in ways that that people just just
couldn't before
what would happen
if and when a satisfactory Theory Of
Consciousness gets found
well
I would probably
get very drunk in terms of Celebration
um it really is something I'll be
waiting for my whole life
um I and I don't know if it will come in
my life
um
I I think first of all it would be a a
revolution in the understanding of
ourselves we would finally know
what we are
we don't because we don't have a good
theory of Consciousness so there's still
this debate what what exactly are we
and we don't know there's no good
scientific answer to that question
there's there's answers around that
question but there's no direct
scientific theory you can point to and
that's what a theory of Consciousness
would give us so first of all there
would be the
change in Humanity's conception of
itself and that would be I think as
Monumental as the theory of evolution by
natural selection which told us
where we came from right
and then there would be all sorts of you
know incredible technological uh
advancement to come out of that I mean
the the ability what you could do with
the theory of consciousness
I mean first of all you can make some of
the best art that's ever been made in
the history of humanity you can make
some of the best art
um you could do you could do some truly
incredible things and second of all I
mean it may turn out as as I I've talked
about on other podcasts and and and
written about uh that you know I am very
worried about Ai and and where that's
going uh but it might be that certain
types of AI are impossible without
Consciousness I think it's very I think
I think it's very debatable if
contemporary systems are conscious I
think most people would say no and I
think I think most of the scientific
fields of Consciousness research would
also say no uh so then the question is
well how do you build conscious AI well
the only way to really do that is to
know what Consciousness is and how that
works so that's an example of
you know something that that could
revolutionize AI for instance um so the
actual the funny thing is about this is
that there's basically no funding
um and and uh
but both at a private level but also at
like a public level right if you look at
like you know tax dollars a huge amount
of it goes to to Neuroscience via the uh
the NSF and the NIH
try applying for Grant to do scientific
research on Consciousness to one of
those organizations and see how it goes
they've gotten better over the years
like I I'll say that like that they have
gotten better don't take that as it's
totally impossible but it's so much
easier to you know get rats to run a
maze and you know you want to look at
the amygdala you know you know you the
the chance of you getting a grant to do
that is you know like uh 10 times higher
right so
um so it's sort of astounding that
there's still this really big gap in our
understanding of the universe
it's not like the gap of you know what
happened before the Big Bang or exactly
how do you reconcile
you know um quantum physics with general
relativity or something these are very
very big questions and it it's totally
imaginable
that the answers to them are
um you know would require building like
a super collider the size of a solar
system or something right
for Consciousness it's like listen if we
all do this every day ever all of us we
wake up our brain you know are the slow
waves recede right you wake up from your
your dream right and and and and and
maybe your Consciousness continues from
the dream right and then the the
Consciousness is a dream gets to be your
your Consciousness for the for the day
right you get some lucky dream that gets
to exist until you until your head hits
a pillow again but
that is that is something that's
accessible and present and uh and and
yet still remains a a a really major
scientific mystery
so I think it's I think it's just sort
of an obvious missed opportunity in my
eyes and I think you need to Galvanize
people a little bit about it I mean
that's one of the reasons I'm so
critical about Neuroscience in in the
book is because I want to Galvanize
people to to to actually address this
how is all of this related to Free Will
we've decapitated a number of people's
dreams so far today let's go in and do
the final one with free will
well I think that there's a few
different ways it's related one is to go
back to some of our
earlier discussion about emergence
so you know if you if you if you pick
out some popular science book that
argues against free will
there's only a couple forms of arguments
um against Free Will and one of the most
common ones is is is basically that you
know your your atoms did it uh whatever
it is pick whatever it is your Adams did
it you didn't do it your atoms did it
um you sort of
we can talk about you as if you know you
use you exist but that language is just
uh for convenience really uh you know
everything is sort of completely
reducible down to your atoms
um and and we don't you know associate
um you know if your atoms did it you
really aren't very strongly associated
with your atoms so then you didn't
really do it right
um
and I think for one the theory of causal
emergence
um sort of
puts puts that particular argument I
think to bed very firmly can you can you
explain how it does that in simple terms
like I'm a golden retriever
um you know there there is there is this
notion of cognitive closure where uh you
know if you you really can't explain
certain things
yeah you really can't explain certain
things of Golden Retrievers uh but but
uh I'll give it a shot so
let's look at that argument it's saying
that well your atoms were the cause of
your actions so your atoms following the
laws of physics were the cause of you
reaching your your handout for handshake
now the question is well was were they
really the cause like did anyone check
and you and you might say well it should
be obvious that they're the Cause right
and what our research has shown is no
because basically because no one thought
to check and while you can't do this
with a simple with a person right yeah I
can't I can't prove this to you as a
person because people are incredibly
complex and physics is very complex I
can give examples that are similar to
that in very simple models mathematical
models right where you have some simple
description of a system and this might
be like cellular automata it might be
circuits of logic gates but imagine a
very simple description of how a system
works like X talks to y y talks to z z
talks to a right and so on and you just
imagine it's very simple
what it turns out is that when you when
you look at higher scales of description
so this would be like for our bodies
this would be like instead of getting
the atomic State what if I gave you the
cellular state of your body right so all
all your cells your biologists would
talk about you know the sodium levels
and they'd talk about you know which ion
channels are open and so on they would
give a biological description or
cellular description of your body or you
could give a description of your body up
at an even higher level in terms of the
musculature and the and the bones and
like all these much larger structures
like organs and so on and talk about
their states right and these would all
be what this field calls macro scale
description so macro meaning bigger
right and so these higher level
descriptions
the question is well do they have any
causal influence
over the future events right and well
again you can't measure that out in the
real world you can create simple
mathematical models where you can look
at macro scales and compare them to sort
of the atomic scale and what you
actually find is that pick almost any
measure of causation you want right
because so so there's a question of
causation people normally think of
causation as this very philosophical
subject actually there's a whole science
around causation now there's a whole
mathematics around causation now a lot
of it comes from Judea Pearl who's a
mathematician at MIT
and he won the Turing award for this
work and so this is there's basically
then this really recent development of
our good mathematical understanding of
causal models
and so you could take a system and you
can look at the causal model of all the
little micro interactions which would be
like the atomic contractions and then I
can look at all like what would be the
equivalent to Cellular interactions or
some other higher scale of description
and what you find is that there's causal
influence that's irreducible down to the
micro scale
despite the system still being reducible
as in you can still say you could still
say pick out
um you know every atom that makes up
um you know you you your organs or
whatever right uh you could still pick
all that out and you could still relate
those so it wouldn't be that the the the
macro scale is not reducible it is
reducible but the causation involved is
not and what that means is that macros
macro level entities can have real
irreducible causal power in the world
and you are a macro level entity right
we don't think of you this is like the
the ship of Theseus or or what have you
right like you're not uh the same you're
not completely identical to your Atomic
State you're some sort of coarse grain
that we that we talk about and that
thing can have really irreducible cause
of power simply from the fact that we
know that in these simple models you can
sort of get this effect to occur and
then it's like probably very likely in
these very complex real cases that it
occurs does it make sense to ask the
question where does this causal power
come from yeah it makes a great deal of
sense it makes a great deal of sense it
makes a great deal of sense both
temporally so to ask where in time so
was it was it something that just
happened was it something uh that
happened a while ago or uh it also makes
sense to talk about in terms of the
scale of the system and that's what this
research has really talked about so you
could say okay what was the cause of of
this was it the atomics state of the
system or was it some macro scale State
and uh the answer is that in many cases
most of the causal influence can come
from macro scale States and we
understand
exactly how that happens and it happens
due to this
relatively non-magical
um a thing called error correction and
it's um it's it's basically just that
well there's noise down at the bottom
and my noise I don't mean like like
Sonic noise I mean like there's noise in
terms of the probabilities of how things
relate to one another down at the
microscopic and when you zoom out that
noise gets smaller and smaller well the
power of your causal influence is
inversely proportional to your noise
right so
um what's a great what's a good way of
saying that so it would be like
um
let's say that I had a light switch that
control the light bulb if that was a
very noisy causal relationship it would
be like I turn the switch and then
sometimes the light turns on but not all
the time right now think about the
difference between that and a light
switch that you can rely on right you
turn you flip it and the light bulb
turns on and off right
um and one would be like a non-noisy
deterministic system and the other would
be like a very noisy system one has more
causal influence than the other because
in one case it's like why flip it
sometimes it happens sometimes it
doesn't that's not very much causal
influence but in the other case I flip
it it always turns the the light on or
off
macro scales are non-noisy
representations of their micro scales so
what that means is that you can take a
bunch of relationships that are very
noisy and transform them into non-noisy
reliable causal relationships up at the
macro scale and that's where you get
this extra causal influence from which
is just something called error
correction from information Theory
um and so I
I think it doesn't prove Free Will by
any means right so it's a a notion of
Free Will has to be more complex than
that but it does open this door to say
well wait a minute now we know that it's
mathematically possible for like macro
scale descriptions and higher level
descriptions to matter causally
that is a necessary fact for there to be
free will because imagine if it were the
opposite right if we could show listen
all the causal influences always down at
the micro scale that would imply that it
really is you know why things happen is
always just your atoms were in some
particular you know Atomic state or so
on
interesting I got sent through uh
literally today out front Robert
sapolski's new book have you seen what
that is I don't know if I've seen the
new one determined the science of life
without free will yeah
we would disagree
um I thought you would I thought you
would well I think I I I'll I'll just
say it right I mean you know he's a
primatologist evolutionary psychologist
right
um neurobiologists I think evolutionary
biologist perhaps evolutionary biologist
yeah so you
you know I think that the probability
like that
when you're talking about Free Will
you're talking about like the the
mathematics of causation like that
that's what you're talking about you're
not and the relevance from you know oh
is a genetic determinism it's like
forget genetic determinism is it just
determinism from like your current brain
state right now is this you is this you
slowly marking your territory here
I think this is this is me saying that
when people say Free Will doesn't exist
and they sort of start that at the at
the outset it's generally only by having
really strong metaphysical
um and philosophical assumptions and if
you actually go and you question those
assumptions
in terms of their details what you'll
often find is that either they're
extremely debatable
um and this would be like logical
fatalism and some of these other sort of
more less less direct Arguments for free
will or like literally disprovable so so
you can you can literally disprove uh uh
the argument so
um I I I like sapolsky I like uh a great
deal uh but but I think that you know
there there's a certain um I think one
thing that I hope my my book makes clear
is that you know these questions are not
uh just just closed and and that's given
the very best the very latest that we
have on what would be the most relevant
scientific disciplines which is like
how you create macro skill models how
causaling modeling Works how prediction
Works in science using
um you know Notions like computational
irreducibility like we had this we had
this revolution in the 80s that people
have not caught up with with chaos
theory and computationally reducibility
those are very relevant and have not
been directly applied
um we have we've had this causal
Revolution those are that's very
relevant and has not been applied so so
I think you know if I want one people
just take away one thing involving free
will it's not so much that you
definitely have free will such that you
know if you look down at these really
basic assumptions behind a lot of the uh
you know we obviously don't have free
will or so on what you'll find is things
that are extremely debatable especially
given what science says about how
the best way to talk about how the world
functions Now versus say 1950.
and a lot of people are using stuff from
1950 to talk about it right and they're
and they're like you know the laws of
physics are working on deterministic
train tracks and you know they had they
just have these really and you know
causation is just uh correlation or
something it's not like counter factual
dependency or something they have they
they basically have this sort of Old
Stock you know World model and if you
look at you know contemporary science
you find a lot of complexity there and a
lot of room a lot more room uh than
people are are led to believe
if a theory of Consciousness was found
would that
inform us at all about free will do you
think would it be likely to inform us
about the nature of free will
yeah I I I think it would absolutely
would and and one reason why I don't
make the claim and I don't in the book
that you absolutely do have free will
but more so that
the standard arguments against it
have been nullified in many ways by
certain advancements in thought
um you know is because Consciousness is
always the wild card you know a theory
of Consciousness is always sort of a
wild card we don't know exactly what the
ontology of the universe looks like
without a theory of Consciousness you
could always pull out some some Joker
right some very strange thing
um and and that would
completely change your conceptions so
so with that said then you know yes
absolutely it could have a huge
relevancy but I'm I'm I'm sort of
cautious I think you can still talk
about uh Free Will and intuitions around
Free Will and arguments against free
will or arguments Pro free will without
necessarily relying on on on
Consciousness I think you can talk about
cause causation and prediction and what
prediction really means you know and and
and whether or not you really could
predict you know someone's Behavior or
so on and what I hope people take away
is that you know science isn't finished
yet so we still have some big gaping and
very personal holes uh left in science
that that have not been filled and a lot
of the recent developments in science
have made things seem much more complex
rather than less and that includes over
things like free will that includes
Consciousness that includes neuroscience
and I think that that's something that
is very much the opposite of what a lot
of Pop side books are out there to tell
you they're there to simplify they're
there to make the world easy and I think
ultimately The World Isn't Easy
Eric hole ladies and gentlemen Eric
where should people go I love your uh uh
sub stack I think it's fantastic the
super sensorium article that you did a
little while ago was one of my favorites
you just put a new one out on the fact
that we don't have a town square and
that all social media is fundamentally
just killing us uh why should people go
if they want to check that out and
everything else that you do if you type
in um the intrinsic perspective Eric
into Google uh Erica the K it'll find it
or just the intrinsic perspective Google
will find it as well
um and my my my first non-fiction book
this is actually my second book from my
first non-fiction book is out July 25th
uh it's called the World Behind the
world you can also Google that and it
will come up with my name Eric I
appreciate you thank you thank you this
was great if you enjoyed that episode
then press here for a selection of the
best clips from the podcast over the
last few weeks and don't forget to
subscribe